this is Island Adventure wow those two
they put the uh in dysfunction
dysfunction
some of you put the fun in dysfunction
they do not this is very different from
adventure Island which I played often on
the NES um it was a little read a bit
game you weird
Fred Flintstone dude throw in the head
you know the first level and then the
second level then you play those two
levels again engineers but you play like
ya know I just I just have for my
education is just a bunch of Millennials
watching this gun fucker these two tough
oh there's no betting about it they are
they're doing it oh god these guys are
old you didn't miss much oh um but yeah
this is an episode to another Mars and
say me
III don't mind in a banana tree did even
she thought this episode I mind her well
yeah was that no I fuck was that
no it's one of those things where it's I
hit the warp pad because I want us to
fall in love and I figure lying to use
the best wait she has she has like a
burger ik that way it never will work
now she's like we are leaving with a
hyper fangirl thing going on there too I
mean it's like look it's yeah feelings
are selling okay but first of all this
guy's awful he's still awful yeah he's
I'm just amazed at how unlikable they
keep him I mean there is just nothing
likeable about this guy and then you
know she turns twisted by trying to keep
them there you know yeah and hiding a
warp and everything I mean if I for days
and days I mean that's fucked up
and that's fucking insane
I wow what a twist I would not have
predicted that based on previous episode
as far as I thought maybe Steven hit it
I thought it was yeah I thought it was
Steven the gems why didn't they come to
save him you know what he shouldn't
abuse the warp pad he'll learn his
lesson I mean I'm really watching this
like you know for someone
okay the putting up with Lars is a pain
but alright I guess their relationships
starting to get back on track I still
don't know if this is a good thing but
let's find fucking I don't even fucking
like large yeah at the end of it I'm
like I'm totally on his side no I mean
it's one of those things were it's like
that was a real dick move I mean they're
just both like where before it's like he
was the dick and she was a nice person
now it's like she's a nice person who
did this unbelievably terrible thing
it's like yeah she saves the day nerve
but isn't this like just I don't know
did you feel like it's a repeat of like
the father faking the injury kind of
thing again like we know where this is
gonna go we have to sit through the
motions and it's like it doesn't further
anything it doesn't teach anything you
haven't learned a million times in a
million you just the same as wait it's
like a crazy psycho ex-girlfriend move
and on top of that hi you kept your
phone on the side ah um but yet no but
it's the same thing it's like you know
on top of the scene this trope over and
over sure you could turn back but son is
entertaining really plus it's an ice
rink
oh but it's one of those things were
it's like I just can't believe like
they're gonna make Nellie this one
character so likable but suddenly her or
at least that choice so unlikable then I
guess it's a joke I guess the joke is
just gonna be there just in one big
dysfunctional relationship and I guess
they're both asking for it now
no it's those played for comedy that'd
be fine but they're treating it really
seriously so I'm just watching us like
this is the only thing that was like a
comedy was the ending which was great
yeah we should do this again so no no
that's funny yeah um what and even the
you know I like the way the island looks
I like the looks any of those rocks have
all the gems and jewels inside whatever
the crystals geodes yeah I love how it's
like the whole island was based on that
rock um the idea of the gem monster
being invisible that was kind of clever
uh and once a while there's a good joke
and even like a bit of emotion like I
said I mean I like Sadie's fine until
that choice and that was just so
desperate this is this is mean
this is the sort of girl who would like
you know be like we have to have a child
to save this marriage or something it's
like yeah it doesn't work that way
it's just like I mean I have the horsie
somebody to like you maybe it's one of
those like just ee-vie my character
doesn't try to get pregnant so many
times has it worked um but no I'm hoping
this is just like one of those really
dumb truck us I never liked wise I mean
that's like to me that's just like okay
if there's an episode with Lars
okay just buck up get through it but you
know as series um person yeah say these
are like fine uh you know but that yeah
that move was such a dick hold
stupid dumb mean-spirited move that it's
like I'm hoping that's like just one
mistake in the writing of the character
or Ike out it doesn't seem like they're
really doing anything like putting this
on me where in Judaism in joke with the
show that anytime it cuts to them their
relationship gets stranger and more fuck
up funny see if it was that that'd be
great but they treat it seriously you
know so that's the point where I'm like
if it was messed up it was kooky well
okay we can laugh at because we're not
supposed to be like that but they're
treating it so seriously and they're not
giving us much sympathy for them or at
least they're starting at such a low
dirty lowdown place look it's so hard to
come looking it a bit out
I'm looking at the description for this
Stephen takes Lars and Sadie on a
vacation to a magical beach to mend
their friendship maybe that was in like
maybe it was about Oh Steven you can't
force two people the but then again she
was straight I don't know I don't know
but then they have like that moment
together I mean it's I think it's
supposed to be kind of like that
on-again off-again relationship which I
don't if it's done well I don't mind in
a show but it's one of those things
where it's like I just don't think it's
it just seems so mean and so not funny
that I don't see the point of it you
know it's it's just one of those things
where I shy I just don't know well I'm
not I'm not catching on to hey why this
would be interesting this episode just
wasn't
yeah yeah you're trying to say it's not
good but you don't know if you can bring
yourself to it well I like the show a
lot yeah it just it didn't really do
anything for me it I kind of
particularly after the past three which
were all really good even the one they
had the trope I don't like it I still
thought was good yeah I mean I this one
I kind of like I don't know if I say it
hate it but I just this is gonna be one
that I'm not gonna remember hmm unless
they call bags or less God knows the
start of something major and I don't
know it but I well we we give him that
excuse last oh well you never know maybe
they're gonna do something good with it
and it's like I don't I don't know I
mean there's ways to do this rice or the
dysfunctional I'm trying to look at the
positive yeah like then there's ways to
do it right uh and I think this is just
kind of a lost idea that they're just
not finding their footing with and
they're trying new stuff I'm sure and
their tribe look that's a good way to
put it that doesn't make a sound why
gasps uh uh well be good clearly they
know how to write characters and they
know how make him interesting know how
to work off a relationship I guess I
guess that's all I can say whatever it
is they're doing with us I don't get it
yeah I don't get what it is maybe maybe
other people get it maybe you will share
it with us God knows you probably will
um you know it's just something that I
don't understand what they're going for
so maybe it's on me oh maybe I missed
whatever but they even even like the
tragedy element at least kind of in the
last episode about the relationship you
could kind of argue it like against kind
like a joker in Harley Quinn thing where
there's almost like this tragedy element
to it but even then you can't really get
because then she does that incredibly
unlikable thing um yeah you know and to
me you're taking cases so much like a
ball I can't I guess is just doing
something right yes it's just mutually
assured destruction like they're both
made for each other to simply just be
miserable I don't know you know what it
feels like to be it feels like cuz he'll
be miserable no matter what and her
trying to get him will be miserable it
he'll be upset she's tried to get him
he's still miserable is it feels like
one of the writers knows a couple like
this is trying to make this episode like
to convey to the okay you use
okay okay now let me let me be clear
here actually that may be a very good
point because I do know people I think
we all know people like this I guess
that's how my thumb is it's very true to
life
it's how does this fit into this show
that is you and I have because I'm like
I know people like this and I'm like oh
that's very much yeah that's very true
but I'm like I don't see how it's I just
feel like this is just some random
detour we just had mmm it's not like
more so than with some of the other
characters so I don't know how they've
got to find a way to fit this better in
with the show it's not dark enough to be
it's just a very sad relationship status
pairing I just like wow that that's
really like some of what I've seen in
real life and it's kind of depressing me
watching it it's certainly not is
entertaining is some of the more theory
but these stories have talked about this
will go like so dark and so tragic that
they'll be a tragedy and you'll be like
you know okay now I see you know the
Great Wall and stuff or others will
really play up the comedy oh the comedy
of errors and stuff and this one just
doesn't seem like I said to have its
footing to know what it wants to be um
so yeah I mean I'm with you I think we
definitely know couples like this but
it's like when you do a show about it so
you can special for a kids show you want
to like get something out of it you
wanna get something of value out of it
uh and I'm just not seeing like the
value of it I mean you can walk around
with a video camera just showing your
neighborhood and showing life and it's
like well good for you but what what are
we supposed to get out of it you can
shoot it edit it and do stuff that you
can get something out of it and to me
this just seemed very unpleasant it's
unpleasant and I don't it may be just
how to not have a relationship but even
then I think there's so many other
stories I can do that better um so I
don't know it's a weird situation I I
don't know we can give the excuse like
hey let's just see where it goes I'm
because we guys said that last time um
so I don't know we'll see what happen it
I think you nailed I think if there's
something really really good going out
we're just not seeing it
um but by yeah you learn something great
more power to ya um yeah I I just didn't
see it if I act
fused maybe the fans won't kill him but
yeah I don't know where I'm at I mean we
can't say like you know oh these people
have no idea what they're doing and
clearly they shouldn't be busy no they
clearly have a great understanding of
people and character and story and
reveals and relationships and stuff I
mean this just is oh my god we get it
yeah Eddie again again so it's a good
show nobody's gonna say that we don't
think it's a good show yeah um so yeah
just over our heads guys sorry I don't
even like the name Lars no one here do i
I never liked him Metallica either thank
you I was thinking that I seriously was
thinking that oh my gosh I mean
Metallica man I don't take the because I
like Metallica where people fall on the
Lars thing anymore like at this thing
look we all just agree oh my if I'm
anyone named Lars annoying even Lars and
the real girl is kind of annoying
ah that's something about that name
sorry for anyone named Lars I hope that
our hope is that we're gonna get like a
hundred email like so Metallica
so people who liked this episode
Metallica fans and all people named Lars
are gonna like fucking crucify us in the
comments Sarah in my life I had to
reverse my name to slough because of you
so to all the swirls out there I'll let
you take that one I I was gonna say
anything that was on him hmm
so uh hey what name wash sucks now